congratulations i thought you did a
great job in this movie
um i i so was this a role that you kind
of had to fight for
because i'm not 100 that when people
think of this character they would think
of you initially
yeah i don't i i i don't think they
would think that either but
um i um i i didn't
fight for it i but i did um make it a
priority of mine once i read the script
which was beautifully written by tracy
um i was like i love the character of
ted i found out jennifer hudson was
playing aretha and c.l was going to be
portrayed by
forrest and i was like yo i went in and
then i heard about liesel tommy who's a
great uh broadway director i was like yo
i need to meet with her they said we can
meet on skype i said no i'm getting on
our planes so i got on a plane
i had just did a show in chicago got on
the plane
met her the next day got up right off
the plane went straight to the office
and was like
listen i went in and we talked about the
character ted and what my
interpretation was and we agreed on
where i was coming from with character
and boom
history yeah man i i really you
disappeared in this movie i was very
impressed with your work
um i i love i'm mad as hell
if i didn't do this movie and i looked
and they had uh uh michael b
jordan because he has too much chest
to play ted you know
i honestly it really worked out though
because
uh it really i anyway let me let me uh
i love learning about behind the scenes
you know what it was really like making
a film so
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about the making of respect
how much work every last single person
on our crew
and our cast did like we never nobody
ever went home and left the set and just
left
their work on the set after work
all the actors we all worked with our
acting coaches
all worked with out of our voice coach
all work with our movement coach we was
like we'd work and prepare for the next
day when we show up to work
to work some more um and the same thing
for the for
you know there was times i'd walk on the
set and i'd be like yo this is so
beautiful i would
pull the production designer to the side
and just be like yo
such beautiful work the set the costumes
the wardrobe
you know clint like everybody just you
know i've i've done a lot of movies
this one movie it was a special uh
experience i'm imagining you did plenty
of research and learned whatever you
could to
to get ready for this was there anything
that you learned about ted
that you really wanted to make sure got
put into this movie
actually they didn't have much written
about ted um
i just so i had to create a lot of ted
ted was going to talk to me
i don't know about it so now
i had to create it and so
in my uh
fascination or or in creating
the character i was like as bad as he is
because
i gotta play romantic lead and villain
so
although he was abusive instead of him
playing
me playing a monster let me go back
to why he is this way
because damaged people damage people and
normally the person that's
hurting another person they're hurting
the most and so
to create a character that had some
vulnerability and
it wasn't just he wasn't all bad he did
try to
rescue her from and and make her career
happen
he had good intentions he just is a
damaged dude that can only take up but
so far
and insecurity and jealousy and those
human emotions
led to that anger and those kind of
behavior so
i just wanted to take it from a human
place so that
the audience would identify because
aretha's no fool
no woman in any relationship with an
abusive man is a fool
at some point they fell in love and the
audience has to feel that
because if they don't when she's tearing
away from him
then where's the obstacle and that's
every woman no woman's a fool
they just but you don't you didn't know
the man that she fell in love with
and so i thought it was important for me
to to uh explore that
again you did a great job i wish you
nothing but the best thank you for your
time
thank you man